par c'est le moment de traque du tout
c'est juste ce dont il parlait et la
magie opère dans tree bagot balthazar va
pour la première fois faire vivre au
public toute la latitude de son art des
influences des rythmes et des tempos qui
partent du berceau de l'humanité avec
des escales multiples un voyage des plus
culturel
[Musique]
super magnifique ça c'est pas du son
c'est vraiment formidable tout ce qu'il
fait c'est le retour comme il dit aux
sources et c'est très important
les thèmes explorés sont ceux imprimés
dans l'album afrodescendants paru il ya
deux ans joyce ou dit gregory louer
thierry vaton et les autres sont réglés
à la même eau relâche
avec mario masse c'est l'évasion total
et puis arrive le partage avec tirer
beaucoup pastel les ans est papa les
banou un niveau identitaire savoureux
que bagot percussionniste a travaillé
des années durant
là-haut ou quatre noms sont l'autre à
voyager cinq ans inspiré et puis ou café
ça et puis di luca fait mon idée aussi
parce que de les occuper par op pas
concrétisé sa tête ou café démunis des
eaux qui ni des compétences thalassa que
toute musique la salle du 8 août non non
c'est encore aucun soutien
alex qui habille le guitariste le plus
convoité du zouk et du manga le chanteur
cali rose du sénégal voilà on les a
presque tout citer après près de
quarante ans accompagné les autres la
grande aventure des scènes nationale et
internationale commence maintenant pour
gbagbo balthazar parole d'une mélomanes
convaincu
[Applaudissements]